but did you have like imposter syndrome
is something a lot of us
struggle with especially you first joke
you write goes viral
i mean there's time in between there but
it's like did you have imposter syndrome
you had to overcome
every day every day especially because
exactly what you just said like
i skyrocketed off of a viral video
and for me
i did the work afterwards and i wrote
material and i
toured and i hustled but getting to that
like
break i know there's so many comics who
went through
years and years of you know mc
feature like driving their car six hours
just to get
a 15 minute spot and then when they get
there they bomb but then they still
drive six hours to the next one and like
you know people like really paid some
dues
to get to where i was starting mm-hmm
so i knew that my dues looked
differently and it was kind of like
when i got to where i was that's when
the work ethic came in because sometimes
if you hit success too
soon you don't have the character to
sustain it
you don't have the work ethic to sustain
it but for me
i i had those things i had a good head
on my shoulders
i had my intentions right i had
work ethic i had character i had faith
i had um all of those things that
sustained where i was and i had my eye
on the prize i had goals i wasn't
swayed by like party over here or let's
just get wasted
and then wake up late for a press the
next morning or whatever like
i was very responsible with this gift
that i had been
given and made sure that i stewarded it
well
so that i could continue to grow and and
earn things from there you know sounds
like you're very organized
i mean sure yeah
you said you have goals a lot of times
comics are like well i'll just do this
six-hour gig for 50 bucks because that's
what we got to do but it seems like with
the internet
and you're an example of that we can
create our own success
with the right intention behind it yeah
yeah yeah
intention um eye on the prize like
bigger picture
understanding like maybe you you put all
this work into creating this video
and it doesn't go viral that doesn't
mean give up
that just means make a few more because
when somebody sees that and goes oh
that's kind of funny i wonder if they
have anything else and they look for
something else
like oh that's kind of funny too and
then i'm gonna follow them on instagram
just
and see and then like a couple months
later you show up in their feed
and then here's your other video that
you just made that is funnier than the
other ones and now they're like oh my
god i'm going to send this one to all my
friends
but if you were like oh see i put all
this work into this video
it didn't even go viral it only got like
30 views on it like people don't like it
like
you you keep creating because you are a
creative person
and you put your creative art out there
and then if people respond to it they
respond to it it's really like
that's not your business what they
respond to if you're creating as a
creative person hey hop breathaverse
thank you for watching and if you want
to help us create more content like this
click the join patreon button and if you
want to help more people find these
awesome videos click
watch more videos